the bodies
of
people
um
being fed to these dogs and dog eating
them and
sitting being frightened knowing that if
they see me they will you know bite me i
think it was
i was not
i was so terrified
[Music]
so rwanda was largely made up of two
tribes can you explain the first
moment where you really realized there
was a difference between these tribes
uh
the first time that i really realized
was a different was when
it was in 1990
i was in preschool in primary school and
um
our teacher asked us are you a hutu are
you a tutti and you will raise up your
hand and i
i didn't really know what they were
asking so i didn't raise up my hand
i went back home and they said tomorrow
don't come to school when you don't know
your tribe so that day that time when i
was sent back home my mom told me when
they ask you next time stand up in the
tutsi so we were only about like two
students or three in the class
and you have that feeling like i am not
wanted i am not accepted
my classmates don't really
like me because of how i was born and i
didn't have a choice about it i didn't
understand why am i being called a
cockroach why am i being bullied at
school why do i have to be beaten or see
people being beaten for being tutti so
those things were happening when i was
growing up and really it's the ideology
propaganda that was leading to genocide
in 1994
what was their goal
for who choose
i wish i could answer that question
their goal was to exterminate
every tutti i remember sitting in the
lounge with with my dad
and my two brothers because my mom was
away he she went to visit our
grandparents
and she was with our last born who was
two years old then
and i said
i'm not sure if your mom is going to get
back um
they are going to kill us because we are
tootsie and he just gave us briefing he
said
you know put on we were already in our
pyjamas ready to go to bed and he said
put on your clothes you know where
layers so we had two layers each and he
said if you hide don't hide together
because if you are together they will
kill you all
the next day on the seventh in the
morning
there were all these people running
around the village i remember
hiding under the bed on that day
they came to our house
and my dad was not there because he went
to hide
they say where is the cockroach where is
inensi that's the word they used to use
in kinarwanda and they are talking about
the
soldiers that were fighting against them
i'm like we don't know where they are
and
so on the same day in the eve in the
evening i went to hide in the bush
and um when i was hiding
i went of course you know our dad told
us don't hide together so i went alone
and i was hiding in
in the bush and wandering around and
waiting i was lucky because i didn't
have identity card
we used to have identity card in rwanda
that's written which tribe are you so
and you don't get that id when until you
are 18 or 16 i think
um
so i wasn't being asked the id so i will
hide in front of people um but there's a
lady
who was walking hiding and she had a
baby
and she had her id and she was just
shown her id
and they just cut her head off and
she had a baby i can't tell how old she
was but was was so young because she was
still
feeding her and and um
walking seeing this woman
being killed and seeing
the child sucking from its mother when
is dead i
was devastated i could not pick her up i
wanted to but i was so afraid to run
around with this baby
and um
yeah i just passed her and went and hide
in the one of the house
you could hear outside you know the
noise and people running oh find that
there are two tuttis passing so people
will be shouting because they saw
someone
when it became about evening i walked
back to
my place
and i went and hide in my you know
what i called a safe place because it
was a petra train which is a
a toilet with a hole that was completely
full and no one was using and i want i
went back and sat there
behind that petra train there used to be
a football field and
you will hear this hutu sitting there
they are drinking
they had alcohol and they were talking
about how many tutsis they have killed
or we killed so and so oh we raped so
and so
and
sitting there i was just
i knew that um if they see me they will
come and kill me
i was
hiding in the in the bush
and people
who to the killers
were running around saying
come out come out with the dogs
i did say they were with the
dogs the bodies
of
people
um
being fed to these dogs and dog eating
them and
sitting being frightened knowing that if
they see me they will you know bite me i
think it was
i was not
i was so terrified
when i ran from that bush i just
ran um
i will say like maybe 100 meters and
then i went i reached to the road when i
hear they're making noise and the dog
running next to me so i ran away and i
fell into the road and they saw me said
come come so someone just came and beat
me with the the big stick they had
that those sticks were kind of big on
the top and they had um
nails on i just fell into the hands of
those people that white and waiting to
be killing us
and they had um you know they will say
if you had money and you will give to
them they will kill you by
shooting you if you didn't they will cut
your head off
some people are they will say oh i will
give you this forgive me but they didn't
even have that mercy to forgive
so they chopped people's head off in
front of me and throw them in that um
that big hole that was there i was numb
i
saw many people killed i knew was me
next to be killed so i wasn't really
worried you know i
i wasn't like oh i'm going to be killed
i was just like
yeah that's what is happening
and it was only when there were two
people ahead of me
um
that someone shouted i don't even
remember who i just heard the voice they
said the banking kegel is being it's
being broken in they were they're
robbing the bank so all the killers
around us the the
attention
was not on the people they are killing
they wanted to go and get money
i survived that day because
of greedy of people so they ran away to
get money and
i run off to the bush again
and stay there
how long were you in the bush park
so i
was
in the bush as much as
three months it was either in the church
which we were being killed and
and
i was hiding among the dead bodies it
was either in the
petra train i was by myself i was in the
field by myself or i was on the queue to
be killed so those three months has been
the longest horror nightmare that i have
like i feel like he lasted for
eternity if i may say because
when we talk about it now it's we talk
about three months
and but for me it lasted forever i felt
like lasted forever because i was not
safe at all
i mean you're only 12 years old as all
of this was going on what was what was
going on in your head
you know when
when the death is all around you there's
nothing else you think apart from daying
there's
i i was numb
i was
ready i knew i will be killed anytime
and i saw people being killed
many times so
i was just
waiting to be killed so i kept going
until
until the last day of
of when i had again where we were hiding
i left where i was and i came to see my
brother he's there he's hungry and i
just sat with him
and the next thing what i hear from the
of people they are talking kigali has
been liberated and who liberated their
country is the
rpf
so that's
when they
all the killers or the people that
they started running away from rwanda or
and go to uh to congo
that was the end that was the end when
you see
arapf in watani coming to you and saying
you are safe and
yeah
i knew that i am in the good hands
what happened to the rest of your family
over those three months
hmm yeah
so um
my
brother my
youngest brother was killed with my mom
and he was two years old um
they dug under
under the
the ground and they put they build
on top of that so they will hide the
children underneath there was about
50 children there so like under two who
could not run three
so the um my youngest brother was among
of those children that were hidden there
and
the hutu came and when they found
they saw one of the parents bringing
food you know found something and
brought for those children they they
poured paraffin
on that place and they just lit to to to
fire and all these children
were banned including my youngest
brother
my third brother who is a male was
also killed during the genocide
i once was with him because
they showed him the grenade
and
he took part of his head
and
i was with him when he was grasping his
last breath
i remember when he is asking me for
water
i didn't have anything to give him so
that's my last
day that i saw my brother being
killed
gone you know
and
yeah and
my second brother antoine he survived
and my dad didn't die
he also survived
but my two brothers and my
mom
were killed in genocide
what impact
does going through something like that
it has been
a long journey to to to go through these
things because um i think what happened
to me
your memory has capacity to to kind of
keep some information
and you don't think about them because
you are not ready i think that's what
happened to me
at that time we are talking about like
five years six years after genocide
three years you know those time of
period ten years
sometimes i will not be able to sit with
people who are talking about
their three-month experience
because it was so painful and when it
comes to april every year
and
that's when i you start i start feeling
my body will actually
feel it and i will have these memories i
will think of
what i saw but
i just want to rush it off because i was
not capable
i was 22 then and
finished my high school and i am out i
have i'm waiting the
high school result to go to university i
don't have anything to do
the job i got was with aegis trust and
the job was to
they had a project 10 years after
genocide to build what they call kigari
genocide memorial
so if you uh did i know what i was
signing up for
probably not it took me
back to those three months
because when i was doing my research
going into the village was to know
how many people how many tutsis family
were living in this village
and you know how were they killed how
was and then my job was to feed back to
the office because they are trying to
build a data of what happened 10 years
later so that's the time if i may say 10
years after genocide
i was just like i just woken up
these things happened to me and then
i lived i lived that life again
it gave me the job gave me
um
responsibility um
to to
to deal with whatever was happening
and that's how um i started
i started the journey of dealing with my
trauma
and but con doing something contributing
to the society as well giving dignity
and respect to to people we've lost
including my family
and how are you today
i am alive
yes how am i today i am um
doing
great i am thriving
in
2004 i made a choice i want to
start this journey of forgiving
is it easy no it has never been easy and
even now i speak about it it's not easy
sometimes people will enter
marriage into who to entities which it
was
they will they will so i know one of uh
my auntie married a hutuman and this man
killed her but i am committed to keep
trying to keep forgiving when people
wrong me when people
are not
making the right choices and that's what
really i want to
tell
everyone
that i get opportunity to share with
and
that's what what i will say
that's what i said
when i met
the man who killed my auntie
and i was sitting with him
and
he looked at me so remember i
this is in 2016
and the last time he knows me
it was before
in 93 or 92
i was a baby so i i know i'm
an adult and he looked at me and i said
do you know me and he said
yes
he could see me through
my my grandma who is his
his mother-in-law
and so
he
i said you know
yes i'm glad you know me i came here to
say forgive you
the forgiveness
is the key to your freedom
that's that that's how i say it
and
it's it's a choice and it's a journey
and it's not easy
but is the key to your freedom
there was a witch doctor who had laid
this child
down put herbs all around her body and
was about to cut her
before
the security guard
found her and rescued her and brought
her to this
baby's home where i was working